[Music]
it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
make your day a little bit better all at
exclusive discounts to start shopping
now scan the QR code on your screen
right now or visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle expert Elizabeth Warner is
here and she joins us let's get right to
it so we're gonna pick up first all
right from iHome we know them we used to
put our phones into the iHome now
they're bringing us these great products
to help us clean our houses so this is
amazing the eclipse is an actual vacuum
that's going to do the work for you so
Nate no more having to vacuum check that
off the list when we turn this on it's
actually going to clean in a really
straight pattern so it won't miss
anything that's me getting a nap in
because while I'm napping it's vacuuming
and doing the work for me when it's on
its base it will charge and guess what
else did it just go over the bottom
right over our coffee table so it can go
from hardwood it can go over and around
things it's got great technology built
in and while it's on its dock the dock
itself will pull the dust and debris out
and contain it in here you get empty
this about every eight weeks so it does
it all for you this is amazing what's
the price so these start off at 239.99
they also have a wet dry vac I love this
it's a cleaner way to mop there's a
clean container of water and the dirty
container as you use that mopping it's
going to pull all that dirt and hold it
in the other container unlike the mop
bucket you know you got the dirty water
and I've seen those at schools and
corporate offices
it's mandatory for sticky messes all
right umbrella yes will you open this up
for me okay this is called a brella
shade now the National Weather Service
says oh oh an umbrella go ahead open
that up your car there you go it goes on
the windshield National Weather Service
says on an 80 degree day in one hour the
temperature in your car is going to go
up over 40 degrees this will bring it
down up to 35 degrees so amazing 25.99
for a set of two that's great so really
amazing my wife is from Arizona so this
is perfect for you yes my daughter in
Miami exactly style edit now this this
is a group of scientists and stylists
they get together and they solve our
problems for our hair well my problem is
Grays they come in I've got black hair
it's such a hard thing to well they're
covered up with this right now so they
have sprays they have powders and
pencils they are going to leave the hair
shiny and they're resistant to water
wind and sweat so they're not going to
run and they're not going to transfer
okay absolutely love it they're 50 off
starting at just 15 so think of how much
you're saving not going can you get that
as a gift or is that disrespectful you
totally can give it as a gift yes all
right so Jennifer Adams this is luxury
bedding soft delicious to the touch five
star bedding at amazingly affordable
prices they are enzyme washed they are
pre-brushed you feel that softness this
is the key to a good night's sleep and
if you go to that five-star hotel that's
great come on over you've got to feel
this hang out oh yeah this is where it's
at this is for that good night's sleep
can you imagine wrap yourself up in this
and this makes a wonderful gift you're
the best Elizabeth I want to we
appreciate you and of course we
partnered with all these companies to
get these deals to buy anything that you
saw scan the QR code on your screen
right now or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now we're